obviously being somebody who's come from
a street background
i asked bernard this question and i
think he said he lost like two million
dollars what is the biggest
l you've ever taken in the streets in
the streets in the streets
because you know sometimes i mean i mean
too nice i shoot dice a lot
shoot and die well what's the biggest
hell you've taken uh
[ __ ] i'm probably like down like maybe
like 150 from
from may to uh last month
damn you again oh i mean [ __ ] you being
i mean do you still do
you still stay in vegas in vegas in the
bay but no i'm not talking about
i'm not you touching from shooting dice
streets oh okay okay i'm on the streets
yeah in the street not in vegas no no
but you but you said about shooting dice
in the streets
yeah you're doing one i'm saying you a
gambling ass [ __ ] bro yeah
we shoot we shoot we shoot like 2 000
crazy yeah but [ __ ] you know this is ups
and downs
you get that [ __ ] right back that should
not be man what's the biggest l you've
taken
at a casino probably like a 50
damn yeah you feel like [ __ ] walking out
this casino man
stomach touching my back i've
that made me stop i had to i had to like
i had to leave it alone i was a sport i
hadn't been in there one day a sports
game 500
and it came out and left 30. yeah yeah
yeah it came out
you know it's like it's a high bro it
balance itself out when i first moved to
vegas that's all i used to do
i go shopping i go i go spend about ten
thousand
go shopping go right to the table get
the money back playing crap addicted to
it yeah so yeah
so i said damn now leave my bags yeah
i'll call him hey mr beasley you left
your bags here i had to go back at the
backside and got the money and went cash
down left and forgot about the
clothes and [ __ ] i bought but i used to
do that like every day
just so craps is your game of choice
because kind of vegas is boring
like if it ain't nothing going on so
it's like shopping studio
or gambling like it's not really too
much to do with strip clubs at night
time i don't really go and the street
clubs there kind of fell off
yeah i don't really go out like that to
the clubs or whatever so i just go
gambling go shopping
and going do you remember uh were you in
vegas when strip hop was popping
that was a movie man it was in there i
remember marshawn came in there turned
up one day someone got
i remember someone got smoked in the
lobby man and that was a it was a wrap
they put the plug on that
you mentioned it remember i don't know
if you remember but i had bought a
bentley
in l.a some years ago and it came back
stolen
oh really yeah and i went to jail for in
san francisco
so the guy he he worked
it or worked her own that spot strip up
pay me back for the car wow